president biden is speaking to reporters
just a few minutes ago let's watch
he went incredibly well we spent a long
time together
i spent i got a chance to spend a lot of
time with gianna and the family
and we just talked about you know it's
[Music]
one year anniversary and uh those even
through
personal loss know that although every
anniversary
is uh you're happy people remember it
also brings everything back immediately
like it happened
that day takes a lot of courage to go
through it
and they've been wonderful and i've
spoken with the negotiators
i'm hopeful that sometime after memorial
day we'll have an agreement
uh on the george floyd
legislation and so i'm optimistic and i
think
they spoke to you maybe you spoke to
some of you
i think they were very pleased with the
time we spent together it was mostly
first
we spent a long time i guess
almost a couple hours what have you
decided
first thing she did when she ran in just
threw her arms around me gave me a big
hug
and uh wanted to sit in my lap
and we spent uh she also
loved the idea that she said i'm really
hungry
and so she said having snacks what did
you give it
well my wife would kill me we gave her
some ice cream
she had some cheetos and i think she had
a
chocolate milk i'm not sure what the
third one was but they were in and out i
showed them all and we spent
time i spent time showing them around
not taking over but
around the white house and they were
interested in
gave them all little mementos
especially her i had a great picture
of uh gianna when
i went down to the funeral
when have you decided to meet with
president putin
so that was the president talking about
meeting with the family of george floyd
on the anniversary of his death
having some trouble hearing that audio
so we are going to continue with the
five
here the washington post just published
the mother of all puff pieces boasting
about president biden's
workout routine and his desire to escape
the washington bubble they also did some
hard-hitting reporting on biden's
favorite gatorade flavor orange
and his cookie preference chocolate chip
here's just a small sample quote biden
begins his mornings with a workout that
often includes lifting weights
and he meets regularly in person with a
trainer
during the 2020 campaign he biked
regularly on both a traditional bike and
a peloton
his current peloton preferences are
something of a state secret however
and the white house press pool can't get
enough
what more can you tell us about the uh
president's um
health regime we hear he's lifting
weights what sort of weights is he
lifting does he have a personal trainer
and what happened to his peloton bike
did he bring it to the
to the white house i have nothing to
read out on the president's uh
private exercise regime uh but i can
tell you having traveled with him
a fair amount um sometimes he's hard to
keep up with
all right so guys we have the
anniversary of the floyd death we have
china covering up the lab situation
we have russia hacking our pipeline
biden's done nothing about it
he let the other pipeline go to germany
inflation
and he's getting asked about peloton
dana what's going on here
you forgot the border and i'm really
bored how could i i'm sorry
how could you possibly jesse are you of
all people
not to mention our problems with taiwan
and the chinese
over there now especially after that
last segment we're probably gonna have
to have like an emergency meeting
somewhere
uh so if you're the white house press
secretary and you get a question like
that it's like home run easy those are
kind of fun but also that reporter
probably knows how to get clicks right
because people like to read about these
types of things
they'd like to do it with obama too but
with president trump it was the opposite
though right it was that
oh he likes his steak well done by the
way so do i
and he eats it with ketchup and also he
eats french fries he has a terrible diet
like those were the those were the
things that reporters would write about
and click on
uh everybody clicked on him but this
kind of thing happens
uh i don't know what he does on peloton
i'm gonna i'm gonna guess
uh greg he probably does hitting hills
yeah
sometimes that's what that's what hunter
does low impact
does the impact what do you think greg i
just found out he doesn't watch cable
news except
for morning joe which explains it
explains it
uh joe's almost as in good shape as the
illegal aliens sprinting across
our border i did that for dana it's hard
to actually conjure up strong feelings
negative or positive towards joe biden
and that's his secret superpower
which allows him to be such an effective
conduit for far left
policies the squad people hated trump so
much
that they they over scrutinized
everything he did
to a point of actually hallucinating
things that he didn't do
but with joe he's just so joe
he just goes along to get along the
media's pleased his punch because they
don't have to work that hard
they get to sleep at night and they're
getting the far left policies
and it really is it comes down to it's
so important to like
your president sure you're going to have
inflation you're going to have a
terrible border and rampant crime that
is
all like 20 20 cities now that hasn't
been seen since the 1960s
we're seeing expanding unemployment
we're seeing media driven racial
conflict
but for god's sake there's no tweeting
at midnight
what a trade-off i am so happy i can
sleep katie my favorite part of the
story they showed part of his schedule
at 9
50 a.m he waits around for ron clayne
his chief of staff
he awaits the president chief of staff
the prime minister yes joe biden's
waiting for the actual president the
prime minister of the united states ron
mcclane yes and then he
waits for the uh for his vice president
harris to also run the show
uh first of all why is the press not
demanding
that the white house physician come out
and give a real detailed
um you know explanation of the
president's health yeah the american
people deserve that
especially after the president fell up
the stairs twice
which could have been a really serious
problem but i'm glad to know that he has
a trainer because he can do some
hand-eye coordination drills
to make that not happen again one
another juicy nugget from this thing he
has lunch with kamala once a week
and while they sit down and eat they see
montages of pictures of themselves that
they had taken of them
doing events throughout the week
i don't know what to say i i mean what
kind of room they're in where they have
that kind of uh
monitor up next and it's kind of weird
by the way just quickly
go do they have a big monitor like that
i didn't know it's like a tv screen
i guess they have to bring it in yeah
anyway i
i just think the press gush is over new
presidents
regularly i mean think about george
washington in the cherry tree jesse
legends get built uh you know dolly
madison the greatest
hostess ever with trump by the way
ivanka and jared they were the power
couple for every cover uh you know so
we had this ronald reagan had it for six
years but he was a pro
until iran contra and then it you know
went away but
yeah it was uh i think this is what
happens right before they start
taking out the long knives for you i'll
wait i'll wait for that one
i'll watch the clock on that those long
knives up next
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else